you're making threats now big man leave
leave before she gets nasty because
i'm having the worst day
[Music]
what's good guys
happy monday fun day hope you're well
man rugs
um love to see you here today guys very
happy to have you always
um
and yeah man what else is there to say
um
guys as always
if you
are watching the ting on youtube make
sure you like the video if you like the
video please please also chirp sitting
in the comments our fans know what to do
when it comes to
matters of the the tongue
matters of the skin they know what to do
they're putting the good word yeah man
they're often yeah they graft and they
build nice relationships that we can
bring to our log cabin and we can
indoctrinate the youths into a
generational cult and that's what we do
here on this channel so please chapstick
in the comments like and subscribe and
obviously use the two
two fingers are deaf to bring the
notification bell i haven't said that
one in a while it didn't come out as
smoothly yeah i said that one in a while
uh guys if you listen to the show on uh
any podcasting app spotify podcast
google podcast amazon music whatever uh
please leave us a nice review uh it does
help a lot with the outreach and with
the current petrol prices and the cost
of living we really can't afford to drop
any more numbers yeah so please guys
help us out allow us to live a lavish
life
even if you can't uh
someone has to do it so if it's a
vicarious team yeah yeah yeah yeah live
through us
if you need to live vicariously for
anyone let it be us yeah yeah and fund
ourselves yeah speaking of funding us
guys patreon.com forward slash shits and
gigs is where you can get basically
nearly three years now worth of um bonus
content it's all stacked up there i know
a lot of you like to binge if you're
ever on the youtube or ever on the audio
thinking why is it only odd numbers i'm
seeing on these episodes it's because 50
of the content is on patreon so make
sure you head on over there enjoy and
get yourself an extra episode every
thursday
and uh
yeah man
we love to see you guys we do we love to
see you we really do we've enjoyed being
here for you the last three years it's
been a great time it's been a fantastic
rollercoaster yeah man um and without
any further ado my boy my boyfriend
fuegs is gonna smack you guys in the
eardrums with a very juicy fun fact so
let's get into it let's go before we get
into the fun fact guys i don't know if
you've noticed but if you look on the
shelf we finally got the
plaque
you see it there 100k plaque 100k plex
so that's boys
that's thanks to you guys man so thank
you for rocking with us thank you for
vibing with us and yeah ma'am on to the
next one onto the midi plaque and we'll
slap that on there as well
so cool fun fact of the day
in 1974 during an interview 26 year old
pistol pete
maravich said
i don't want to play 10 years in the nba
and i have a heart attack at 40. he went
on to play 10 years in the nba and died
at the age of 40. ra yeah used to play
for utah jazz
yeah i've heard a pistol pete before um
what the [ __ ] was this justification for
saying that i don't want to play i don't
know for ten years and dive ahead
what are you doing to yourself i don't
know so just for more context uh january
5th 1988 uh marovich collapsed and died
of heart failure at the age of 40 while
playing in a pickup basketball game in
the gym at first church of
nazarene in pasadena california oh he
weren't even playing playing he went
playing he was just fascinating
scrimmage
law of attraction wow yeah that's a
weird fact and that's a weird turn of
events
oh rags
don't just say [ __ ]
the tongue is a powerful yeah don't just
say [ __ ] into the universe because
she'll repay you
what are you doing bro the tongue will
spud you in a different way yeah he's
vexed yeah yeah that's that's um that's
peak yeah but i would love to know why
he even said that
was it a ting back then that if you just
play you just get heart attacks like
what's the deal i think maybe it was one
of those ones where well i have no idea
because i wasn't born in them times but
my assumption is
it was one of those ones where you're
active for so long because you're in the
nba for so long and then once you leave
you just become an old fart and you just
start not exercising eating [ __ ] do
whatever you want to do maybe that's
what he said i don't want to die after
10 years you know maybe maybe yeah i was
thinking about differently yeah because
once you stop
like this lifestyle oh yeah yeah
training and regimen blah blah you just
fall off oh bro trust me
going from when i used to like compete
in like physique shows every year to
then just stop in
bro
eating disorder
eating disorder anything and everything
bro because like when you're dieting
you're so strict so when you're not
dieting you eat like [ __ ] but it doesn't
matter because all the weight you gain
you're just like convince yourself it's
all muscle yeah so then when you dye it
down again you can look even better than
you did last year yeah yeah so it's just
you get this like eating disorder and
then once you just pack it all in and
you're not doing any competitions you
still eat the same way you were eating
before yeah just like [ __ ] and that goes
on all year now all year round and you
don't lose anything bro i used to i oh
my god when i stopped competing yeah
coincidentally i stopped competing
around the same time
i started an office job so i stopped
personal training and stopped competing
within the same kind of six months okay
so when i started uh my office job and i
was no longer like on my feet all day
bro
i put on weight immediately it's the
first time in my life where i actually
put on weight where i could see it and
feel it i was like this is impossible
yeah like how is this happening that was
me in um that was exactly the transition
from going from working to hospitality
to the first lockdown oh oh you did paul
i put on weight james you man if you
might want to scroll back to the the
videos of us when we were um in my old
flat on the sofa yeah my cheeks were
rosy oh they were
my cheeks were rosy and chubby beard was
long and your cheeks were like yeah yeah
you actually were bro because i saw a
random thumbnail of that i saw a round
of thumbnail over there like a few weeks
ago and i was like [ __ ] no i put on
weight brother did you really did put on
weight brother
i couldn't believe what i didn't even
notice it until you look back now shame
i didn't notice it until i looked back
no one told me yeah
no one told me until it was too late
[Laughter]
it was long it was long
because i bought it in my head you're
wearing a do-rag and a man you top
you wearing a two-rag at a man utop
that's not even the one i'm talking
about i'm talking about the one where
i'm in um
i'm in a sleeveless vest top oh oh you
can see the fighting yeah yeah i
remember i i'm a society in my cheeks
and my droopy titty
where the bottom of the tear your
stomach touched yeah
there's one connecting like [ __ ]
orifice like it's just dead i was i was
a hot mess yeah so it was either to be
fair it's a hot mess i oh
i hated locked down so with every part
of my existence i hated it it was it was
a bit above me i hated it and i enjoyed
the relay section because i was always
on my feet at work oh yeah i i enjoyed
the furlough yeah i enjoyed not working
that was banging when they
when they redid my photo for a third
time
i was gassed
because they gave it two weeks then
asked me if i wanted to do another two
weeks and then on the third time it was
like can you do another month
[Music]
i remember because i was at your house
when i got the call
because it was either because when i was
at your house it was either i've got a
call and as if i'm going back to what
time all right
and i remember saying to you i might
have to
stay tonight and crack my laptop because
no it wasn't even tomorrow it would have
been then yeah it would after that zoom
call that i had at your house it was
okay it would have been a case of like
log on now and finish your day out and
you're working like back from now yeah
or um
you're gonna be like your photo is gonna
be prolonged yeah yeah we got on there's
like sorry guys i'm so so sorry you're
gonna have to do another month for photo
everyone's like oh
i was gasping
i remember i came out of your bedroom
screaming yeah yeah yeah yes bro i
remember
oh there's a good time is this the last
life now though yeah [ __ ] i couldn't go
back to work man sorry you man but i
couldn't go but i couldn't go back to i
couldn't i i literally couldn't i
remember those last few weeks you did
the hell for me i know there were march
was helpful because i was in and out of
work and i was only working three days a
week yeah
and i think i went on holiday
just towards the tail end of my on my
last day and i was like damn what have i
done to myself i should have just quit
on my last my second to last pay as
opposed to waiting another month i know
what you mean but yeah
i was is i was living in myself by his
ways right you've got a little segment
for us
yes so [ __ ] viral thing that everyone
keeps sending all day every day we're
finally going to jump in guys peer
pressure is a [ __ ] right guys everyone
has been sending it to us me separately
james separately she's a 10 buck he's a
10 buck so here we go i've screenshotted
a few for both all right she's a 10
but she's the oldest daughter with anger
issues
[Laughter]
she's a 10 but we watches grey's anatomy
when she's sad and to cry more when the
character dies oh stop stop that
immediately there's so much grazing out
of me if you're re-watching episodes
we're done we're done that's too much tv
yeah yeah it's too much tv
she's a 10 but needs constant
reassurance otherwise she thinks you
hate her
oh that's fast
she's a 10 but says bro romantically
what fam
what
i would need an example the love of my
life couldn't call me bro bro
romantically oh bro
what
that makes no sense oh wow
she's a 10 but her love language is
biting
[Laughter]
that is [ __ ] funny
wow i wasn't expecting that that's jokes
she's a 10 but she puts horror movies on
to help her sleep at night
horror movies and murder podcasts
murder mystery documentaries of saturn
oh my god
she's a 10 but her personality changes
after every movie she watches
oh
yeah that's a sociopath
she's a 10 but has to communicate her
feelings through letters
i couldn't receive one letter who has
gonna receive one letter foo hat
i promise you i wouldn't entertain that
foolishness
open your mouth and speak to me tell me
don't write [ __ ] down and post it to me
fam
i wrote you a letter just to let you
know how i truly feel and it's pages
right in the back
exactly that's exactly what i was going
to say
11 pages front and back
oh i'm not reading that [ __ ] that damn
that's the same thing when i get
paragraphs on whatsapp i'm going to see
more so if i ever see a bell me
bell me why it's it's unfair for me to
have to read all of this facts because i
can't respond i can't respond to
everything my mind is clouded now it's
too much information
whatever it is i just have to say sorry
guys i can't yeah i hear you i
appreciate that i'm sorry because i
can't even digest it there's too much
information it's way too much it's not
fair it's not fair at all
she's a 10 but still thinks one
direction is coming back
fam speaking of one direction oh my god
did you see any you probably didn't see
did you see any of the clips of liam
payne on logan paul's podcast by any
chance no a few weeks ago no oh bubba he
ain't right oh swear he's weird for a
[ __ ] one he's weird what are the emails
what's he saying what's he doing
there was
viral
like videos of how similar my man is to
like david brent like ricky gervais's
david brent from the office like he's
like talking about like how like um
he said a story about like dead serious
about like how one direction was like
he's like the founding father of one
direction like simon picked him and then
shows everyone else around him but he
says with chest brother i think you're
certainly your nose i was probably snot
bro
this hay fever thing this is ikea i'm
doing right now on the tube
i'm i've sneezed so much that i don't
care bro
um gone yeah
yeah you're nice
yeah yeah yeah um so
um yeah yeah and he was talking about
like how
how like
he wanna he wants to fight like justin
bieber or something
and just like how he would like oh
they'll be like oh can you fight anybody
oh yeah
oh your chest bro oh yeah is that what
how talk about like how one time in the
changing room it was like oh there was
another one direction member that like
pinned me up against the wall
um and i politely told him if you don't
remove those hands you're
you're he said there's a there's a small
chance that you'll never be able to use
them again
and they were like they were playing
along with a minute oh wow what happened
next yeah
he removed those yeah he removed those
hands he knew what time it was that's
how he's speaking
liam payne liam payne oh
pharisees they're owning it bro and he
he comes in with like
four different accents throughout the
thing
really he's got like a posh english
action he's got northern actually he's
got an irish accent he just he he's
lived in that bubble too long bro
it's oh it was green that week that he
was on logan paul's podcast
i pray he didn't come and take talk he
was all over it bro it was it was brutal
he did
yeah sorry god
she's a 10 but i'm scared
this one is weird she's a 10 but is
emotionally attached to peter parker
what fam
makes
zero sense that does make zero sense i
couldn't even laugh at it properly my
brain was just trying to figure it out
while i'm just like fake laughing
she's emotionally attached to peter
parker
what ah she's a 10 but she hits every
curb
bro
yeah stop that she's a 10 but she's got
no eyebrows
is she attended is she a 10
oh she's a 10 but she left me please
take me back i missed you
yeah
stop yeah no
wow
god
she's a 10
but she shits five times a day
[Laughter]
oh god this is going to be a sweaty one
yes it's going to be a sweaty one
she's a 10 but she threatens to chop
people's dicks off
wow
that's bare women
i'm i hate how many women that is bro
she's a 10 but she's the [ __ ] of
babylon
she's a 10 but thinks charles leclair
and carlos signs are a boyfriend
wow
no that's west oh god that sweetened me
she's a 10. but she doesn't remember her
last proper meal
that's women yeah that is women
all right we're moving on to he's a 10
now yeah
he's a 10 but he's you but he uses
snapchat as primary form of
communication that's bagger man yes red
flag
man
he's a 10 but he's had his first love
already
okay
[ __ ] he's a tent but breathes the same
air as women
i've seen that one [ __ ] sake
he's a 10 but he says without me when
you tell him you're about to take a
shower
that's yucky basically that's yucky bro
he's a 10. but he literally wants
nothing to do with you
[Laughter]
bro
oh these heartbroken ones are killing me
bro he's a 10 but publicly interacts
with porn on twitter
[Laughter]
[Applause]
nah but i'm swaying bro
oh
[Music]
but started freestyling when we smoked
oh my god
oh
oh oh i'm sweating these are getting me
way harder thank you bro
did you hear me that way we get me give
me one more get me bro
[ __ ] it now
oh i can't even get the words out
oh
he's a 10 but says zoey and please oh
[ __ ] off bro
he's a 10 but has a girl best friend oh
sorry g rate yeah i hate rain
he's a 10 but he literally doesn't like
me back oh [ __ ] he's a 10 but he nuts
after 5 minutes
sorry g
that is valid man it just he's a 10 but
he doesn't want to date you publicly
oh
god
he's a 10 but his pillows doesn't have a
cover
wow
that was a that's uni james that is uni
james bro
he's a 10 but he's clinically
narcissistic oh [ __ ] fair [ __ ] me
he's a 10 but he only posts me on his
close friends
oh
he's a 10 but he's also a dj oh [ __ ] say
sorry
he's a 10 but he answers the phone with
yellow
yellow
yellow
oh he's a ten but he's a cancer [ __ ] me
oh god oh yeah that was it that was an
awesome fair play
some of those twisted me up i i'm not
glad because people keep sending to me
i'm not gonna like the ones i've seen i
didn't even laugh at any of them i was
like i was a cool concept but i kept
getting sent there yeah yeah yeah and i
was like all right man just leave it
i wasn't expecting some of those fam
publicly interactive porn onto her
it's the funniest thing i've ever heard
that is so funny
oh god
fam that's so
jokes
that is hilarious oh god right
straight off the back of that i was
going to give it a break for the laughs
to settle down yeah but fam there's
there's saturn that i came across that
you might have seen
have you seen this this little thread um
it was on twitter it was like drake's
the type of guy that
yes but i didn't see lowe's i saw a few
foo hat
foo hat
let me pull this up for you okay some of
them took my breath away
okay oh my god bro i have to run it up
right let me find
oh fam
some of them sent me bro right
right okay so drake's the type of guy
right
right so this whole thread is called
drake's the type of guy right
drake's the type of guy to say
well well well what do you have here
when he sees his enemies
i could hear him actually in like a
district me i could hear it
drake's a type
[Music]
drake's the type of guy to go up to a
school shooter and say this isn't you
what the [ __ ] fam
drake's the type so they have pictures
as well drake's the type of guy to float
in the air when he smells pie
bro
oh
oh drake's a type of dude to get smacked
by his girl and say i deserved that off
fam yeah
i can see that oh drake's the type of
guy to say there's not enough room in
this town for the boat
oh my god
jokes are kind of got to say awkward
after an argument with this awkward
i can see that happening
[Laughter]
oh my god that one said
west bro
[ __ ]
no more mr nice guy you know drake's the
type of guy to close his eyes when he
hugs his homies bro
oh [ __ ] sake wow
drake's the type of guy to say oopsie
daisy and he drops something
oh [ __ ] sake
drake's the type of guy to join in on
the girls night out
the type of guy to just rub his hands
and say let's dig in before
i hope i can say this all right i need
to say this
right i found my back's cramping
laughing like this
drake's the type of dude
drake's
[Laughter]
this
box sake right let me try again
come on james
drake the type of dude to say pee you
when he smells something bad
pee
[Music]
[Laughter]
takes a time for dude to say
oh wait wait wait wait wait drake's the
type of guy that when he's mad at
someone he covers his ears and says
[Laughter]
oh my
gosh ah right a few more
drake's the type of guy to surprise his
friends with a visit from the tickle
monster
oh my god
i didn't know where that was going when
you said surprise oh you didn't know
when i was going oh wait that was the
last one tickle monster you know my
visit from the tickle monster wow
bro wow okay the props to the bread who
sent me that he screenshotted every
single tweet of it he could find fair
enough bro
fair enough i was reading it in the
peace and quiet of my own bed
laughing fam
that pu
sweet hit me
p u p
u that's funny that's funny that's funny
i'm laughing so hard
i don't think you might get it i'm
laughing so hard
that my bad back is pulling on my hip
flexor
the the core contractions from are just
doing bits to the left side of my body
it's hurting bro sorry b
p u oh my god you got a question for me
no
yes um [ __ ] me
i hated that
so pretty similar to
um
the conversation we were having on
patreon about um
the am i the also in terms of
um the guy [ __ ] the mom whatever
so
let's say
obviously we do what we do now um
podcasters content creators
but we're always busy we're active like
we don't have time for our homes okay
you get home one day
you go into your room and you see
that your pops is [ __ ] your girl oh
for christ's sake
all right
what do you do i don't know if you had
let me is the answer
the reason why i asked you this question
is because i saw a video of it on
twitter about a girl clocking her mum
[ __ ] her man
oh i i didn't see it but i saw someone
post
i saw a post where it's like there was a
video of the mom beefing the girl mm-hmm
oh [ __ ]
no i don't want to hear that this is
what you do with my mom is you serious
he's lounging
and you're just sitting there quiet
really you ain't got to say so you just
no i don't want to hear that
yeah i'ma put it on facebook i want
everybody to see the two this is right
here what they doing in my
bed
my bad i steal your money i don't care
who you are obviously you don't care
that i'm your daughter right you over
here sleep away my baby daddy this my
[ __ ] baby daddy you don't clean
because i'd be at work i'd be at work
you don't i'd be at work
[Music]
i'm behind here he's just i've haven't
got time for any of this chat whatever
you might need to chat about
i've just nutted yeah and i'm knackered
femme
hurry up and get out someone or everyone
get out cause i'm tired i'm so shattered
i've got time for this fam he doesn't
give a single didn't flying [ __ ] yeah he
didn't care
it's unbelievable bro yeah
it's unbelievable he didn't say what he
didn't move a muscle because even if he
doesn't care about her like if i was in
that situation
and
i i was i was him in that situation and
my girl came in and clocked me [ __ ]
her mum even if i don't care about the
girl anymore the situation will make me
want to dip oh it's too awkward it's way
too awkward because the fantasy's gone
now yeah me banging me back at the
moment wow yeah yeah i mean me knowing
that my girl hasn't found out yet was
like it's just right you saw juice but
now we're all in the same room yeah the
showard's over get me the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah i'm getting up i'm getting dressed
he didn't move her
because
he's from he's
to have she said that's her bed is not
the mom's bed yep to have that level of
chest he just he's been caught doing all
sorts before this yeah yeah he has he
has this
yeah she didn't even say that's her man
she said that's her baby daddy
he does what he wants in that yard what
he wants when he wants the mom's excuse
said you don't cook and you don't clean
these are twisted bro
mom just needed a young pipe she did and
he just wanted some milfy tom yeah she
was cobwebbed oh you needed some god she
needed a side yeah
there's no way i could walk in on my dad
banging my girl
jesus i think i'd
i don't know bro i'd either just
switch off emotionally yeah and just
leave and never speak to anyone ever
again or like it's just a murder scene
i'd fight him you'd fight your dad
i think i'd have to
really
but like
sorry
go on i was gonna say i'd have to
because i don't think
like you said you had to switch off
emotionally but i would switch i don't
think i switched off i'd switch
you know yeah
the the person that's fighting him
wouldn't be me
oh yeah like an alter ego yeah yeah once
i'm done
i'll switch back to my normal stuff and
just dip i won't even there's nothing i
need to say yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
literally nothing i need to say
i can't imagine
experiencing such
disdain for a parent
as to walking in and seeing your parent
banging your partner
the dad thing's even worse than the mama
as well your dad banging your girl
bro
bro
yeah you can't walk in on that yeah you
can't i pray no one's ever walked in on
that oh someone has someone oh yeah
someone has fam billions of us out here
someone's walked in on that i can't
imagine what they went through
especially if you're our age where your
dad can still smack you up yeah oh rags
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is your mat you
have to murder him
yeah i put sign in his superstar oh yeah
bro has to be a cyanide thing because it
can't run
it just can't run i'd have to fight my
dad oh i would have to fight i guess i
would have win or lose i'd have to fight
him to get off my chest
oh because we can't
we can't argue about this and then have
breakfast the next day we can't
we just can't we'd have to square it
somehow so you'd have breakfast after
you smacked him out
no but i'm saying i can't just not do
anything all right that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah i have to smack him up
and then i can do what the [ __ ] i want
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've got it off
my chest yeah yeah i can't let that sit
in me and then continue the days as we
were going yeah to be fair i think i
could actually yeah to be fairly i think
the only way i'd be able to forgive my
dad is if i beat him to within an inch
of his life
and let him know who the man in this
situation is
regardless of who you [ __ ] yeah
who the man in this situation is
that's that's that's that's the only
thing and then i can forgive this old
[ __ ] y'all
who thinks he's bad yeah then eventually
not straight away but maybe a year down
the line because he knows if i give him
a little
[ __ ] yeah he backs it up
and you give him one of them on it on
his cheeks yeah it's all right man [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh that's um that's a
[ __ ] situation to be in man i can't
possibly imagine what scenario in which
your girl would want to [ __ ] your dad
anyway
what's he promising her what's he
promising her piper
what did my dad have to look like
hey there's a lot of there's a lot of
handsome older men out there that women
like bro it's true man a lot there is a
lot bro they really love a silver fox
they really do
ah
to have someone fancy your dad more than
they found you because women only
upgrade facts bro it's common knowledge
when women cheat they upgrade they don't
cheat on a guy that's uglier than you
they just don't they just don't they
just don't it's just a it's a rule of
thumb they just don't do it like if you
ever ask any woman would you [ __ ] a guy
that's uglier than your man the
immediate answer is why would i do that
what kind of question is this yeah what
kind of dumb question is it yeah of
course not
not again
guys we recorded the patreon episode
earlier and i was sneezing man's got the
hey i've got the hafe bro
it's licking me in a way that's not
making sense
this the the pollen count this year is
up up it's sky high i don't know if it's
global warming or mutation
it's a mutation thing it is it's a
mutation thing
these bees are pollinating in a
different order
and it's [ __ ] me
oh my god that's a mutation tick for
sure for sure
bro my sinuses can't bear it sorry g oh
my god
my receptors they're just they're just
getting murked by it guys we're gonna
take a very very very quick break to
obviously plug our boys over at manscape
guys sweaty sac summer is approaching
and it's time for you to prioritize the
comfort of your crotch bra facts that's
why the kings of crotch comfort
manscaped has spent two years
designing the most comfortable boxer
briefs out there guys you've heard us
say this time and time again it's the
fabrics they're using are not signed off
they're creating stuff
they haven't been signed off bro they
slide on then they slide yeah the
reaction that it creates with the human
skin it don't make sense
but they're the slipperies
and the elements that they're using
haven't been discovered yet
but anyway guys i've had the honor of
testing these out and i can say bro like
i just said it's the softest fabric of
any underwear
it's breathable it's like
gills for your groin bro and they are
not lying they even trademark the dual
pouch
so you know it's real
i think it's time you guys invest in
your family draws so let your bulge
breathe and get 20
off and free shipping by using the code
sng sierra november golf at manscape.com
guys one more time from the top that's s
ng sierra november golf manscape.com
grab your boxes today let's get back to
the episode thank you very much
but yeah
that's the worst possible scenario foul
facts facts facts facts jesus anyway
you've got trash news as well so trash
news have you have you seen this
bloke has nike shoes tattooed on his
feet because he's tired of paying for
new ones bro i saw a picture of it i
didn't read into it or whatever i saw
the [ __ ] picture they looked terrible
by the way
the tattoo looks [ __ ] nice you
it actually doesn't look that bad it
doesn't look that bad
throwing me off yeah it's the dumbest
[ __ ] it's stupid
so he's just on a thing
bro let me read it out i can't imagine
how much that must have hurt
not worth it it's not worth it it's
really not worth it
the caption was the aliens must be so
baffled by our behavior
[Laughter]
the cost-saving bloke enlisted the help
of the south african dean gunther to
tackle his unique ask after the tattoo
artist went viral for inking a realistic
six-pack onto a man's stomach
the 34 year old who owns his tattoo
studio dg tattoo art in manchester
impressively drew this the trainer's
design on the client's feet free hand
before making before making the drawing
more permanent with a trusty tattoo pen
and ink
drawing the tattoo on my on the free
hand was the most challenging part i had
to make sure everything flows on the
contour and blah blah blah a stencil
wouldn't have worked and it had to be
freehand
once that was on the tati was
straightforward so in reality the guy
has the rarest pair of nike shoes to
ever exist it doesn't even mention
anything about why the guy ever wanted
it in the first place obviously because
he didn't want to pay for new ones but
what would what is going through that
can't be the reason for him see the
thing with
stuff like that
there should
tattoo artists should be able to say no
oh they can say no like they should say
no more often yeah okay maybe that they
should say no more often because that's
the dumbest thing i've ever heard
it's crazy surely you
there is no
there's just nothing in this tattoo like
there's no meaning to this tattoo
because you are going to wear crepes
again i don't care what you say yeah
yeah yeah i don't care what the tattoo
represents yeah yeah yeah you're going
to wear crepes again
it's a dumb waste of time for everyone
and if i back off if i'm if i'm the guy
and i'm backing off my socks and stuff
and a girl sees me with [ __ ] nike a
nike crap on my phone your whole foot is
my whole foot this tattoo trainer
she's gonna be like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah bro rags he don't care but
yeah i actually think on that one
in regards to the artist saying no i
think you'd be surprised
how desensitized these men are to
hearing [ __ ]
on a daily basis i've not thought about
that on top of also on a daily basis
because i was thinking about it like
when this thing was getting done
like
these lot
spent hours
doing the same type of tattoo
all the time because people love trend
tattoos as well so it's just like the
[ __ ] chandelier thing under the boot
that every girl got off the reality oh
yeah
yeah yeah people love a trendy tattoo
bro so they'll just taiwas have spent
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours of their life doing the same
[ __ ] tattoo yeah on so many
different people that like someone rocks
in and just says bro i want air force
all over my [ __ ] feet he's probably
happy for it gassed ah sick gasps
my brain yeah yeah yeah as soon as he
found out the stencil weren't even going
to work into a freehand it's probably
even more gas because these men are
artists at the end of the day imagine
being an artist just being asked to do
the same thing all the time true that's
demoralizing it is but yeah [ __ ] that
just fam mr dummy [ __ ] i would have said
if i i would have had to have said no
that big i'll pull them to a site like
are you sure about it yeah i know you
want to pay me i know i'm really the
recipient of the p are you sure about it
yeah yeah i'm willing to
i'm willing to not get paid on this one
if it means that you can go home and
rethink this whole thing take a day yes
because you're chatting [ __ ] right now
yeah yeah you're hyper on saturn and i
don't want to really really hear it
to be there because whatever you're
going through yeah it's not my problem
yeah it's not my business yeah yeah it's
not worth it yeah so just go home and
just like rethink this whole thing
[ __ ] it up right
i have a weird like it's not under my
[ __ ] and it's not really even a fan
request it's more just like a story time
from a fan okay so i saw it and i was
like oh
dear
let me find it just to kind of gauge our
reaction and type thing kind of okay
let's have a look see
right
okay right so this got sent in on
patreon
so
me and my ex-fella live uh live together
the whole thing
i pick him up lived or live lived okay
past tense so ex-fella so yeah me and my
ex-fella live together
i pick him up from work one day and he's
silent the entire ride home
we get home
and before i've even closed the front
door he bursts into tears and starts
telling me this whole story
the friday before i'd stayed at friends
to babysit he was messaging some girl on
whatsapp after things things turned
dirty on the messages she revealed she
was actually his cousin
and wanted 150 pounds to keep her mouth
shut
if not she would tell she would tell me
and his whole family that he was down to
[ __ ] his cousin only 150. how are you
you must be young
young fan they must be young they must
be young or poor or both
he told me almost a week later about it
all because she rang asking for more
money no
but he didn't have any to give
i instantly broke up with him obviously
obviously but before i left i made him
ring his close family and tell them the
entire story in front of me to make sure
they knew he was the one who [ __ ] up
there's twists and she didn't ask is she
the [ __ ] yeah i think i can
provide some some insight to it
regardless wow
so
her man
was just doing some sex dinting
with a t with a with a chick on whatsapp
the chick took all the juice knowing
they were cousins the whole time that's
[Music]
conniving is the word foo had
as soon as she had enough dirt said
safe
run me 150 quid real quick but i'm
telling the whole family that you're on
some incest thing
he says for [ __ ] sake
transfers of the 150
and then a week later she's like fam the
150 was nice
but let's double that now
message
i haven't got two pennies to run
together
but
you're gonna have to tell who you're
gonna tell
because i've got nothing left i've got
nothing left say what you want to say
say what you want to say
[ __ ]
so before she gets a chance yeah he goes
to his goal and says babe i'm [ __ ]
sorry when you was babysitting the other
week yeah i got into
i got myself in a little sticky
situation with a thing i didn't know was
my cousin that turned out is my cousin
now she's blackmailing me multiple times
just blackmailing me do you know what
that reminds me of
there's an episode of big mouth where
one of the predators is text texted his
cousin he does um it's a cousin like a
third remove cousin type thing
and they're sending each other stuff and
he tries to send a dick pic
and he does send a dick pic
yeah yeah [ __ ] andrew in it andrew
yeah yeah [ __ ] hilarious bro he
didn't care it was his cousin and she
was a certified freak as well she was a
certified freak seven days of the week
but she didn't give a [ __ ] that episode
was too funny hilarious when he got
hilarious fell to his knees they
screamed she's your cousin for [ __ ]
sake the mum screamed at him bro
the dad has never been so disappointed
he couldn't believe it the cia came and
said take him away
now big mouth is too funny bro too funny
big mouth is hilarious but fam i
couldn't be swindled into that situation
top fam this is the thing as well right
so he came clean
she broke up with him
and then
made him call his mom and whoever to
call the whole family while she stood
there
so that and tell them the whole
situation anyway
so that they would all know that he
[ __ ] up and not her yeah she wasn't
the problem he was
big man listen to me right now listen to
i don't know what level of shame he was
dealing with yeah
but
if i confided in my girlfriend about
some infidelity yeah and said look
i haven't done anything yeah but i was
chirps in one yacht and what's up
she's family and she's blackmailing me
she blackmailed me once twice and i just
can't afford it anymore so i'm telling
you the truth now yeah
and you and then she comes back to me
and says ra swear down
well
it's over just so you know i'll be like
[ __ ]
and she says
and you best ring your whole family and
tell them what you did so they don't
think that i'm the blame fam big man
thing
yet no
no sorry i don't think i will
because that you've already broken up
with me yeah so that's yeah what's the
gain
why why would i do yeah yeah why would i
do that why would i do that like i don't
understand well if you don't do it i
don't want you going around telling
everyone that i [ __ ] up and broke yeah
listen i don't care what you want
because you're not liking
five seconds ago you're not like you
don't have my girlfriend i owe you
nothing
so if you're leaving leave why i owed
you was the explanation i gave you five
minutes ago it was your choice yeah
everything i owe you you have
you then decided to exit this
relationship so and threaten me and
threat you're making threats now
you're making threats now big man leave
leave before she gets nasty because
i'm having the worst day
[Laughter]
a man said he was quiet throughout the
whole ride before she closed the door
you burst into turns into tears
and then you dumped me anyway
i'm not telling anyone
you must believe i'm painting you in the
worst light say what you want to say
it's over now what else do i have to
lose
what do i have to lose hitting you in
the worst light
bro
a man just did it
he built his mum and his dad and his
sister and all they're stupid he was
already getting black men from their
cousins so the cousin was already going
to do it anyway anyway and you're either
going to do it anyway so the least i can
do is just block my family and get on
with my life why would i bail them and
tell them the truth
just so fam she caught him at his lobby
to catch him to do that yeah yeah sam i
could be crying my house out don't leave
don't leave as soon as it's certified
you're leaving
oh and before i go
you i'm gonna stand here while you bail
your whole family and tell them what you
did you must have lost your mind
you must have lost your goddamn mind
i will wipe my crocodile tears on the
spot
ra what was that
cool who
why
because you're a dog and they need to
know
do they though because it's my mom yeah
because you're gonna leave and never
speak to them again you have to do the
rest of my life so what i'll do is cut
my losses here
and you can [ __ ] off
because i'm not betting anyone it was
nice
i tried
i tried but it was nice and nervous yeah
yeah i've already dug my grave bro
thanks
i need to get out of this hole i'm in
because i need to
what i need to do is bail my mum and ask
for another 150.
that's what i need right now
all this bell my momma tell her what
happened that's not all this truth no
since
think about it on your way home i need
150 yeah yeah i need pee is what i need
because i'm getting multiple threats
from multiple numbers i'm an enemy of
the state and i need help so if you're
not hanging around
finally [ __ ] off so i can start making
the real calls i need to make
i need one
bro
oh [ __ ] bro i don't know who she thinks
she is making threats after you just
dumped me bro at my lowest oh that's
wild get out wild accusations yeah fam
some people will do something [ __ ]
she must have hung a carrot in front of
him she must have said sat in to make
him do that
because there's no woman that could be
like you know what you're a piece of
[ __ ] i'm done and then be like before i
go do x y and z i'm not doing anything
it's done yeah yeah it's literally done
yeah yeah rags
anyway [ __ ] it that's like that's like
me committing a crime
and then the jury tells me i'm going pen
for 10 years
no appeal no nothing and then say before
you go you better stand in front of your
victims apart no no
i'm already going to jail for it just
take me to bed already
stand in front of your victims
no so save each other hey man and
said man on his way you're a fool
just take me to ben that's my punishment
i'm not doing anything else i've lost my
wife is that not punishment enough ally
i've lost my wife you're leaving me i'm
not bailing anyone
[ __ ] idiot that was hilarious that
was funny that was actually hilarious oh
jesus but yeah thank you to uh the nice
lady who submitted that because
i don't know how you got him to do that
but he's an idiot bro
that um do we have anything else before
the itchy questions but no no no no no
no no i was gonna say that bodes
well into the ig question oh go on then
so the ig question of this week guys is
how did you find out your partner was
cheating on you okay gang gang i've got
loads and like the week before james i'm
just gonna run through them oh [ __ ] i'm
just gonna run through them let me just
breathe and release the tension on my
head from this laughter because when you
do stuff like this yeah
it sends me bro all right let's go his
girlfriend dm me on insta with death
threats while i blocked him on
everything
wow fam their text exchange their text
exchange saying [ __ ] doesn't count
so he doesn't need to tell me
the psychic said you better [ __ ] tell
her a man replied [ __ ] don't count
[Laughter]
wow another girl's knickers in my
washing i think at this point he wanted
to get caught oh he did he did he did he
stopped caring
his fiancee turned up to my door we'd
been dating for two years
[Laughter]
kept lying saying he was somewhere else
when really he was inside my best friend
oh
fam
man to man away from the camera for a
second those best friend nuts
pun intended
fruit
that's the juiciest plum he's ever seen
oh
that's the juiciest peach he's ever seen
what
yeah man [ __ ]
jesus you can never bang my girl by the
way
future girl you can never bang him by
the way
because that's all nuts oh it's i
couldn't do it no i'd do that to you i
would never ever i wouldn't i couldn't
comprehend such oh i know you could i
wouldn't be able to oh i know you could
honestly for days i would think you're
joking
for days i think you're joking
i i don't think you get it if i was ever
hypnotized by that
and actually
banged her i would threaten her with
death
if she told you bro
i i'm not joking
i would threaten her life
i would make it so extreme yeah that if
she ever did tell you yeah and the
reason she did it is because james
threatened to murder me yeah you'll be
certain she's lying yeah all right yeah
right i think it's so extreme yeah yeah
yeah what did he threaten to do to you
yeah it should come out so heinous about
james would never say just something
that's how bad it would be
that's a weasel yeah if i was ever [ __ ]
ties [ __ ] to that kind of level but yeah
i would never do it but that's a juicy
fruit that is a juicy juicy
that's the peach
peach he's ever seen jesus peter's ever
been into
[ __ ] it up
[ __ ] sake fam
had two other girlfriends at the same
time as me then i found out he was still
legally married
wow he's got time on his side he must
deal in cash only oh right he's stealing
cash only because he doesn't have a nine
to five he doesn't have it he's [ __ ]
where is he from he's from turkey or
saturn
jeremy white i just feel like he's just
from like
a very
polygamous esque nation
they've got ancestry and polygamy okay
found dry shampoo in his car he's bald
oh dread
a laminated poem in his bag when i was
packing his lunch and i made what i
found a laminated poem in his bag
and i was playing wow
[ __ ]
i need to know if it was from him or two
fab either or pig
very pee laminated
energy brother
his girlfriend who who he shares spotify
with [ __ ]
changed the song to jojo get out right
now
[Music]
wow
oh imagine
he sent a picture of his dick that my f
what he sent her a picture of his dick
that my face was also into another woman
who aired him
i'm so confused
that my face was also in she's sucking
him off and she might have been in the
background or something
wow
she aired him
that reminds me of that reminds me of a
time where i it wasn't a nude but a girl
sent me a like a
sexy vid of her
not knowing that the bread she had
banged was also in that video i was like
do you not realize there's a there's a
man in that video she's scurried off oh
no she got read off she didn't know what
to say
like no one was naked or anything but it
was clear that these guys were either
just banged or they're about to go out
and do a thing oh wow and she's sending
you
she sent me that video i was like
there's a man
i can
i opened it and saw him do you know what
i mean i was rattled fam she must have
been drunk she wasn't paying attention
she wasn't paying attention she didn't
look at me
i couldn't believe
i couldn't believe that's hilarious
could have never told me
i forgot
until now oh no i was thinking show me
[ __ ] show me why are you chatting
hilarious oh wow fam found an email to a
swingers website and emails from him
confirming his attendance
[Music]
rsvp
that's jokes confirming his attendance
ah
he told me his ex had moved to hong kong
for a year abroad i saw them lips in
tesco
oh [ __ ]
found messages between my sister and the
girl she sorry found messages between my
sister and the girl he was cheating with
she was helping them
what
she was helping them she was helping
them for what purpose
she's not even getting anything out of
this i did
she was helping them
that's like right now right now uh one
of our mutuals messaging me oh where's
james i'm trying to smash he's like oh
don't worry i've got monkey paddies yeah
i'm great occupy he's in the studio
we're gonna be wrapping this episode in
about 20. you need to be done in tech
cleaned and out the yard she was helping
them
fam
your whole world would crumble
james i wouldn't know what way's up
i would
destroy this whole room
i will smash that black on your head 100
fam i would destroy this room what the
[ __ ]
why are you helping them for what reason
is he [ __ ] you too like what's going
on she was helping them that's too funny
oh oh wow
fam
this one was me oh go go go go instagram
when they used to show your friends
activity
remember that back in the day when you
used to like something and it showed up
that was even a thing fam yeah you got
called
relationships
i hated that thing with a passion
i hated that thing with a passion i know
you got caught constantly on there were
times where obviously working on society
i'd finished working like two o'clock
then i'd go on like a binge like oh like
two or three can't sleep
someone in the morning i'll get
screenshots of like
um girls random girls sending me oh
you've like bag of man's things i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's so big
it's just so big why was that a thing
man i don't know i'm so happy they did
their thing and just locked out as soon
as they locked that off it it was
heaven's gate's open yeah yeah
i remember seeing the update and
thinking foo hat is gassed
he can just like with no conviction
there's no consequences dated you out on
there oh wow i liked who you followed
who you commented on who you this i was
like wow
instagram's really the op
they are really the op
[ __ ] it i remember when that was a thing
and you would tell me that you just kept
getting beefed by it and i was like fam
just stop liking hoes pictures and i was
like instagram
is four
oh that's so funny i'm just doing what
they told me to do
[ __ ] it out jesus
all right recap how did you find out
your partner was cheating on you
one brother wrote through my arch
nemesis girl telling me
because i told her to because i told her
some home truce while cussing her out
but she up she went up to me with the
comeback fam
that happened to me really that happened
to me in a mcdonald's car park oh about
a decade ago hit me
fam
this is how i found out my girlfriend
was cheating this is actually this is
actually wow i actually forgot this ever
happened
wow wow
okay
wow i forgot this ever happened
premise
right so
check this out i must have been like 18
at the time i um it was in like uh
it was in like the summer break of first
year of uni okay so maybe i just turned
19. okay i'm with my girlfriend at the
time
i'm in my little renault clio with my
girlfriend in the passenger
and my brethren and his girlfriend
in the back
okay we're in a mcdonald's car park
eating apple pies at like midnight yeah
carrying away
laughing
just laughing that's the funniest kkk
you've ever done in your life wow
just laughing bro not caring the world
yeah and my girlfriend had just had a
massive fallout with her best friend of
like i'm talking like her whole life
so we're in a car park eating apple pie
is having a jolly old time yeah and
we're parked up at this very specific
parking space in the car park fam
there's not another car in this whole
car park okay
straight off the bat
the ex-best my girlfriend's ex-best
friend yeah
parks up next to us
window to window
and just start eating and doing their
own queches okay and i'm like ra i look
at my girlfriend i look at their best
friend and i'm like that's a declaration
of war
she wants to throw hats
i can't believe the audacity audacity oh
yeah i couldn't believe the audacity
yeah yeah yeah so
we're sitting there we give it a couple
minutes and i'm like i'm not i'm not a
[ __ ] bro i'm not going to sit here and
just you're clearly not going to say
nothing i wrote down my window i'm not
sure when i said right on the window
she wrote down the window i was like
what is this like what are we doing here
she was like what are you talking about
i said why why are you parking next to
us she was like bag of space some bit
there's not a car park there's not a car
here like park anywhere why you parked
here she was like bro it's a free
country i park where i want
and i was like
swear swear
i'm now because i thought i was i was
bad yeah i'm taking on my girls battles
for me yeah yeah yeah so we're going
back and forth back and forth
you know how women are
that didn't last seven seconds before my
girl at the time started piping up yeah
she's lean up over me yeah beefing this
girl over the [ __ ] fam
over the handbrake just lean over over
me fast just screaming yeah yeah and i
was like all right stop screaming this
is foolish you're just like that i'm
just like this like an idiot in my own
whip yeah so this goes on for a couple
minutes
and then she's like um
then she goes
the the ex-best friend starts talking
about like ah
don't chat to me with [ __ ]
like say
you ain't been cheating on your
boyfriend all year
i found i pushed my girlfriend out the
way and was like pardoned
and she was like yeah his name is this
he lives in leicester that's what i'm
going to do he lives in leicester my
girlfriend she's chad [ __ ] why the [ __ ]
are you lying but the reaction of her
yeah was so far over yeah like so like
she passed angry hours ago like the way
she reacted to her saying this was like
i can't believe you're [ __ ] saying
this yeah i can't be out in mind yeah
yeah yeah it was a complete it was so
true
like the way she reacted to it was so
true like she got way too angry too
quick
and tried to be like you're lying you're
a [ __ ] liar shut the [ __ ] up
and she was like yeah yeah say that say
less and she was and she started talking
about [ __ ] that they were doing together
so i was like
so anyway that all died down yeah i
didn't talk to my girl for the rest of
the evening i dropped her home yeah
dropped my boy home and i linked up my
bedroom the next day same bread i was in
back a car and he's like
last night last night
what was that about yeah and i was like
bro i don't know pause
i can't even imagine what them were in
the in their faces in the back they were
just like
if i was in the backseat i wouldn't say
a word fam i would just listen and drop
my giggles listen and hold my giggle
all i was thinking the whole time was i
wish i was these man in the back
i wish i would this is the juiciest
gossip going
and they have no war here yeah they're
just spectators it's the juiciest [ __ ]
and i'm dead in the middle of it it's
just vex smacks
my relationship's crumbling yeah and
these men have just got a front row seat
so i'll link up with my boy the next day
and he's like
bro like we need to get to the bottom of
this kind of thing fox and i was like
bro i don't know what to do and he said
right he said fam i don't condone this
but his girl was very close friends with
my girl so he said bro
how about he's like i'm not gonna lie to
you i've got my girl's password on
facebook
why don't we log in
just go through the conversations that
they've been had in and see if any red
flags pop up and i was like bro i don't
think i want to do this and he was like
well i want to check if she's a cheat
anyway cause all this chase cheating
chat has got my guard up
so he was like i'm gonna do it with your
consent or not
for my pc yeah my piece of money i'm
gonna read it
so if anything pops up i'll tell you
i was like do what you need to do bro so
he did it
and from we're sitting there sitting
there side inside inside and i can hear
him like
[Music]
he said
and then was like you're like i think
he's winding me up yeah he's i was
thinking in my head i was like he's 100
gone through the whole thing not found
anything and just to stir up some gossip
is just gasping at me fam i heard
i said well grandma
he said bro i'm not even winding you up
you have to see this to this boy i still
didn't believe him
and then he said this [ __ ] is saying
boyfriend number two
i said wow quarterback a group sitting
grab the screen i see the thing and his
girl is messaging my girl saying how are
you and james and also how are you and
boyfriend number two
and then my girlfriend at the time is
talking about our um
things are kind of okay with james
homeboy in leicester i came around last
night we watched a movie
nothing happened but xyz like he's super
nice he's all better trying to touch my
legs and all this stuff and i was like
[ __ ] hell
it was brutal
damn i think
i i didn't i don't think you've ever
told me the car parked thing i've told
you the boyfriend number two yeah he
told me the boyfriend number two and
like the fiasco afterwards oh you said
you're rocked by a dad's house yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i've been getting
down here but yeah it got dry yeah it
got heated
but the car particularly said to me the
car parting was mad wow but yeah that's
it's so funny because as i'm talking
about it i'm like oh wait that's how i
found out my partner was shooting on me
i completely forgot about that [ __ ]
out nuts um okay i'm a breeze up now
yeah
his baby mum came to the door saying
when are you going to come home to the
kids
what is with the next thing
when when are you coming home to your
kids
and you're just doing fiascos
fam wow i'd want the world to swallow me
oh 100
yeah he admitted in counseling because
he thought he admitted it in counseling
because you thought it would save the
relationship married for 13 years i
divorced him oh my god
found a three found a three-page
back-to-back letter from a girl begging
him to break up with me how much he
loved him and how safe he made her feel
during sex
[Laughter]
nah
that's i don't know why that is such a
[ __ ] slap in the face that our next
thing is saying how safe she felt in
your man's arms while he was banging her
oh my god
that's love that is
that's the definition of love
wow she emailed me after we married
she wanted to let me know after seven
years he's toxic
that's pika oh
wow
i went to a dinner with my parents he
was there sharing spaghetti with her
like some lady in the trampty
[ __ ] sake man
his little brother told me because he
felt bad
broke up with him and then went on the
rooftop and threatened to jump off if i
didn't take him back
bro amanda will do that
it's so embarrassing
ah i introduced myself as his girlfriend
to his co-worker and he said i thought
he was married
imagine oh
i'm rocking jaws
i couldn't scurry after the toilet leave
my messes there and you there i'm like
ah be right back just gotta go toilet
introduce yourself yeah tom sarah sarah
tom
i like oh yeah his girlfriend i was like
oh girlfriend i thought he said he's
married he was married with a couple you
and then i just come back larry dar
finished on the toilet and i just see
awkward silence i'm breaking tom's nose
bro
[ __ ] me what's wrong with you bro what
is wrong with you brother also who
brings your sighting to some work
function what the [ __ ] [ __ ] up what
the [ __ ]
he ain't got care in the world man some
people just don't give a [ __ ] they don't
give a flying [ __ ] wow
lefty's phone open i looked like
flirty text messages with other girls
we've been together for two years my
number wasn't saved
[Laughter]
nah wow this man just showed up to my
house in another female's car no [ __ ]
given
he's a drug dealer he's actually a drug
deal he just doesn't give a [ __ ] a phone
call came through as dan i answered i
answered while he was showering it was
his ex danielle
when his bro changed his whatsapp status
saying congratulations bro on his baby
not him bro imagine seeing that
imagine seeing that i
i'd break down james
i'd break down imagine
seeing that
his brethren who i follow on facebook is
putting a post atting my man
saying congrats on the new baby
i'm not squeezed out a thing femme i'm
flies are here
i wouldn't be able to to can't
comprehend it
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is a parallel
universe thing yeah it's a matrix thing
this is [ __ ] i don't know spell
this is witchcraft it can't it can't
congratulations on the newborn
no
with a mixed race baby emoji
that couldn't bank
oh my days were stalking his socials and
noticed he was he was in another girl's
highlights named mine
sorry
fam he crashed his car went to see him
at the hospital another girl was in the
bed next to him
wow oh my god i was writing his third
year dissertation for him when the holy
spirit told me to go through his phone
this
this [ __ ] had a squad of hoes and a
baby on the way
and he's got her doing up dissertation
oh he's got the game on lock
he's got the game a lot on in a
chokehold brother in a [ __ ] choke
hold he's not letting go
he's just not letting go he's drunk on
power squad
man said i set up her apple watch saw
her x's car bluetooth after i made her
remove it i threw up oh wow
bro fam
imagine
listen to me
i don't know why that one's hit me in my
chest
imagine
seeing your girl's exes
cars
i can't even get through it your girl's
x's cars bluetooth on her phone and said
get rid of that we don't need that
anymore as a joker thing and she's like
sorry you see her delete it and then the
very next week you see it on there again
again
she was in the [ __ ] car again
connected to the bluetooth automatically
i promised you i would vomit bro as well
i would vomit bro threw up i would throw
us because i don't know why i've had
i don't know this never happened to me
but i i can't
i really can't stop it that's the one
that would get me out of all of the ones
that we've seen
that's the one that would truly
she takes me down
she just gets in the car
straight away the bluetooth just
bro oh yeah you'd be living she's just
doing up joyrides
she doesn't care
flagrantly she doesn't give a [ __ ] about
connecting her phone to his whip family
how often are you in here often
often oh that would crush me bro that
would truly crush me because i he's the
real man in there yeah i think that's
what i was getting me he's the real man
in this situation
one of us is the [ __ ] and one of us is
the man and i'm katie the [ __ ] i asked
you to delete it you don't respect me
enough to even keep
tabs [ __ ] oh wow
all right a few more
she hid him in my trunk
we got stopped by the cops and they
thought it was a kidnapping
[ __ ] man my friends came and showed me
his grinder profile
that's intense
that's a sit-down type thing like fam
you're gonna need to take a seat sit
down bro
we found our i'll hundred 100
claim it's a fake account oh rags right
hundred percent so i got a house come
home so the day i die fake account you
can you might can say what you want it's
fake
any man can get my pictures from
anywhere
this [ __ ] face
so i'm not entertaining yeah yeah yeah
yeah appreciation i'm not justifying
nothing i'm not showing you my phone i'm
not showing you my emails
it's fake and this stops here this
conversation ends here so say the last
thing you want to say now because we're
not discussing this after we stop
yeah your friends are all ops all of
them every single one of you they
probably created it
they've wanted me out of the picture
from they've been watching me out
they've been trying to get their all
enemies bro
all right let me bang for you the last
one all right let's go
i checked my bank and found a thousand
pounds missing from my
my
savings
sent me a video of her sucking dick
while i was in afghanistan no
[Music]
no
that's not on fam
that's not on
his side chick was audacious was
audacious enough to message me saying do
better
xoxo
[Laughter]
on some gossip melting side chicks
chicks confronting chicks have the most
bollocks they're audacious bro the most
bollocks ah
his wife came to fight me turns out i
was his mistress of three years oh
that's embarrassing man fam i found my
name saved on his phone as uber eats
[Music]
fam imagine going through your girl's
phone
seeing uber eats clicking and seeing
your number oh your name your number oh
i'd want to rip my hair out your number
is uber eats and then in 219 i wouldn't
be able to breathe james
your whole relationship is a lie it's a
facade
you're a side man and she hasn't even
got the balls to tell you your side man
she lets you think you're main
uber eat
she must giggle every time oh
every single time
she must giggle too much 100 i mean i'm
in a group chat for banter
i've met the brederins oh wow
they all know i'm uber eats you e
you e
[ __ ] it up bam they rock up like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he came home from the club at 3 p.m the
next day telling me how he was wingman
in for his cousin
oh wow 3pm
stop stop
coming home from
3pm stop no no no no no you want to tell
me you're a wingman for your cousin
[ __ ] little liar 3 p.m p.m
stop stop doing that
that's a long time james
fun
that's so late you've got no excuse
you've got no excuse i promise you
i promise you if it's a choice between
coming home at 3 p.m or just starting a
new life somewhere i promise you i'm
doing the latter
starting
i ain't coming over 3 p.m ever
after a night out
[Laughter]
3 p.m
this is
yeah
some i just don't give a [ __ ] don't they
just honestly don't leave or stay i
don't care i'm knackered
i'll come on when i want
3 p.m bro
school's out of time
i'm
picking up kids and that oh
no no no no that's insane oh my god he
was up [ __ ] all night and slept the
[ __ ] in
[ __ ] all night slept all day slept
eight hours clean
stretched and warped
same gums same calm
slept a full eight hours she was like
where have you been fam i'm i was on a
win man i was like a wingmenting baby i
didn't leave i couldn't leave i was
begging to leave
3pm don't disturb me i'm knackered bro
that's insane
[ __ ] out right guys girls
oh jesus that got funnier and funnier i
did um thank you so much for today
apologies for my haver i'll try and fix
it for next week
as always guys you need to catch us on
patreon.com forward to our shits and
gigs so make sure you get an episode
every thursday head on over there guys
tell a friend to tell a friend and as
always love love love
[Music]